>> I'm Peter Levene, I'm the Chairman of Lloyd's,
the insurance marketer
in London.
I know there's been a lot of talk here, in
the press, and around the
world about the financial problems that have
happened.
One thing I would like people to say, to know,
and I say this as
Chairman of Lloyd's, the insurance market,
we're not a bank.
The insurance market is the insurance industry
has come out of this
pretty well.
We're in good shape.
We were throughout the period.
And before anybody says AIG, I think you'll
find that most of AIG's
problems came from their financial products
business, not their
insurance business.
But I think it's easy to demonize people,
and quite a number of us need
demonizing.
But we must be sure that the baby doesn't
get thrown out with the bath
water.
Everybody the whole world needs a good, strong,
able financial system
which we had until 3 or 4 years ago.
And it's up to the industry.
It's up to governments and regulators to get
it right.
And I think it's up to everybody else to impress
on them they need to
get it right, but without demonizing them
and trying to help them
through it.
And trying to explain that they need good,
reasonable financial
services which they need either for personal
life or for their
businesses.
And I think people need to try at least to
work together on it we might
get a better outcome.
Thank you.